foreign
s Us in Salt Lake City Serena welcome to
the show
hi thanks for having me sure how can we
help today
uh yeah so my workplace wants to set me
up with a credit card for travel and
events and I don't want to take it
because I've never had one so wondering
what do I do instead because I'm in baby
step three do they want you to apply for
one and get one or do they want you to
just give you a company card
I think it's a apply for one because
it's like technically through American
Express
but it's a business card that's through
the company but it has your name on it
is that the idea yeah it has my name on
it it would go on my credit score which
I don't care about and
I would I would have to just basically
take receipts and they would pay on the
credit I guess okay how often are you
traveling for work
uh twice a year and that's what the card
is for are there other expenses
that are more regular not just for like
flights and hotels and stuff and like
during the event when I need to get food
well couldn't they just book that for
you ahead of time are you traveling with
other people
I am and that's what we did last year
but basically they didn't like how
complicated the process got so they were
hoping I would do it this way or
basically I could use my own money and
they would reimburse me
so you can use your own money
yeah but since I'm in baby step three
I'm hesitant to I usually don't have the
funds to cover how much that would cost
yeah if you're talking hey when it's 700
bucks for this work trip you're like I
don't really I don't have the funds to
cover that so just just to give you an
insight into like when George and I
travel
um I'm just and I'm doing this not to
kick you while you're down I want to
give you and Business Leaders listening
to this another alternative
George and I are gonna go be on an event
um we're going we're going to catch a
flight next week
the company will book the flight
the company will book The the rental car
and then on our desk will be an envelope
with cash in it that we're responsible
for and I've had to I've lost a receipt
on the road or I tip somebody a lot and
I and I've got to cover that cash but
I'm responsible for what cash is there
but the cash just is sitting on an
envelope on our desk
and
the ID here's the deal you're using your
money either way this is your credit
card and your credit and it's your your
butts on the line here and if your
company decides to not pay you back it's
this you're gonna owe that credit card
company the same as if you just use your
own debit card and pay your own money I
hate that for you that they put you in
this position that's not your job to
quote unquote reimburse
um what would they say if you just went
to them and say hey I don't do credit
cards I'm not comfortable opening one
um is there a business debit card you
could open for me or can you book it all
and give me petty cash for the road
debit card and basically they gave me a
weird look like why would I do a credit
card
but I did talk to my manager and once I
explained to them how I've never had one
he understood that then that it was more
like a value Choice than just simply me
being difficult yeah and uh but I don't
I have a feeling that their response was
basically okay you'll have to use your
own money and then we'll just reimburse
you so I have a feeling that would be
the responsible when's your next trip
June okay how long are you going to be
in baby step three four
uh probably for a few more months okay
would they give you cash ahead of time
if you said hey here's what this is
going to cost can you give me the cash
ahead of time I'll deposit it and I'll
pay for it
that's an option I just think there's
always more than one option and so if
they're just like well this is the only
way there's a lot of ways and people
think we're crazy because we there's
literally not a credit card in this
company we Dave only has a business
debit card we have a business debit card
we use petty cash on the road and it's
it works every time one of one of my
favorite lines of Dave's uh old Dave is
when people used to say I can't believe
you would ever give your employees a
debit card with access to some of your
company's checking accounts
and he said he would always respond I
can't believe you would hire somebody
that you don't like to carry your
business to customers with your name on
it that you don't even trust with a
couple of grand out of a checking
account like how would you hire somebody
that you wouldn't trust that way and so
I I I I don't know I I just hate that
Serena's business has put her in this
position you pay for everything we'll
cover you that's not your job man that's
the business's job if you're doing
business travel and if you travel with a
co-worker or leader and they want to put
it on their cars and start getting
reimbursed they can have more rewards
good for them and you won't have to deal
with this so I would just look at every
single option possible to get around
this stupidity appreciate the call